yeah I took let's see I don't actually
remember the first song I ever composed
I think I think probably the four you
know I we did a lot of these creative
activities growing up I think that I
laughs cuz you know my mom is also I
mean she's on the one hand an incredibly
creative pedagogue and is very good at
drawing people out too she's also a
pretty strong personality so I'm
thinking that probably the first piece I
ever composed probably when she told me
to said oh you know you should write a
piano piece are you writing your piano
piece or excited something like that
maybe so there's probably some peace
maybe when i was in middle school that i
can't remember now I did take
composition lessons when I was in high
school so I wrote you know piano pieces
I wrote some chamber music I I don't
think any of that was particularly
interesting I don't remember too much of
it I did have I went to fields than here
in New York so quite an interesting
creative school and I actually have more
close friends who've stayed friends from
high steel stand than I do from
Juilliard as a matter of fact there are
a lot of like-minded spirits and one of
my friends there was a very good writer
he's now a big screen writer in
Hollywood and a terrific musician so the
two of us had a kind of two man music
group and we'd supple you know I put
headphones you know there was no such
thing as an amplified cello at that
point so I took headphones turned my
cello on its side kind of like a
gigantic base and put headphones on the
clamp them around the belly of the cello
so they were like a microphone and they
amplified the cello and he played guitar
or keyboard and we wrote a lot of songs
together so the first songs that i
really like were actually kind of pop
songs that we did together and I used to
we had tape recorders at home and I used
to go into the studio and record
multiple tracks or change the quality of
sound things like that and then I mean
the first music that I remember really
investing in that I composed was kind of
the second I got to college to
university california at santa cruz and
they were they started out being for
kind of a music history course or a
music theory course or a composition
or so not really where you'd expect to
do anything interesting but i think the
the bug of writing music had just been
growing in me and and that was the right
environment for me to say oh my gosh
this this is me you know I've got a
million ideas and you know I want to
have people play these pieces and get
their things I want to think about in
terms of structure or how I want people
to listen and so I wrote quite a bit
that first year at Santa Cruz and then
just kind of kept going
yeah so the way I listen to music goes
in waves depending on a lot of things
kind of how busy I am if I'm in between
composition projects if I'm starting a
new project so the only time usually I
listen to the radio for music is with my
daughters when my driving into the
school are driving them somewhere and
it's always I think they'd kill me if I
put the radio on to a station that I
wanted to listen to it so it's always
one of the air stations so I listen to a
lot of I mean they're 15 and 12 I must
say and just in this last year their
taste has evolved from or evolved it has
changed from you know really vanilla top
40 you know either totally pop or hip
hop you know they're kind of two kinds
of stations these days and but you know
now they're listen to a lot more kind of
indie music and so I listened to a lot
of just music the teenagers are
listening to exam around them and then I
exercise I do rowing on a rowing machine
in my we live on a farm right outside of
right near boston and i have a big barn
that we converted to my music studio so
i go there early in the morning and the
first thing i do is is rowing and that's
when i listen to a lot of music so i
wrote for about 40 45 minutes every
morning and put on my ipod and it's a
huge range i mean that's when i listen
to either things that I just love and
know very well and just want to pay
attention to it's also where I listen to
things I that are new that I want to get
to know and things that you know things
that are new might be new recordings of
traditional repertoire by people who I
really like as a pianist named Pierre la
hi ma who I've known for years who's a
specialist in contemporary music but
also has been recording a lot of Bach
and every time he comes out with
something new I'll listen to that very
carefully I listen to you know new music
by composers who are interested it
to me I listened to some you know some I
don't know if I want to call it pop but
you know some interesting artists who
catch my attention I listened to in the
mornings but strangely the thing I
listened to seventy-five percent of the
time when I you know exercising with my
headphones on is English Elizabethan
music or tutor Elizabethan music so
music from like about 1450 to the early
1600s and I mean I could and this is
music that's attracted me for years ever
since I was probably in high school and
you know i love bach i love beethoven i
love mozart i love the beatles i love
you know stockhausen and i love many
things but for some reason I come back
to Elizabethan music because a little
bit like the Beatles it has its it i
don't think it's an accident that it's
english England has had a lot of really
bad periods of music but but it's had
several amazing periods where they found
an incredible balance not just between
music that's rather complex and also
pretty direct like the Beatles you know
I mean everybody likes it because the
tunes are memorable and I mean any
beatles song is perfect it gets to you
right away but if you look at you know
the the orchestration and the way the
voices blend and the way the instruments
are used and and if you listen carefully
to subsidiary of voices which are not
the main base line to the main harmony
it's very very I mean I know it's
complex is the word but it's very rich
much more than most pop music so it's
managed to combine complexity and
simplicity in a very special way and I
think it took influences from all around
the world England's a little isolated so
when it clicks it and and tutoring
Elizabethan music's like that it's um
it's it's extremely calming I mean it
always takes me to another place it's
also very very stable and simple at the
same time you know these
melodic lines that do the craziest
things you know much more interesting
than what people were doing in other
countries and it's also harmonic and the
English learned in my view how to use
harmony much earlier than the French or
the Italians of the German so you have
these crazy lines colliding against each
other whether it's string music or vocal
music and at the same time these
beautiful chord progressions that are
you know very modern in a lot of ways so
I just keep discovering new music from
that period you know new recordings or
somebody will discover at some castle
but you know a trove of music that
nobody ever played before and for some
reason I listen to that a lot I almost
never these days sit down with a CD or
my laptop and kind of just listen to a
piece with a score way I probably would
do that while I while I'm exercising
silence and you know one of the
paradoxes about the way I live and also
about my work is that definitely one of
the reasons that I went into music and
especially in decomposing is that I love
setting up an environment where I can be
by myself for long periods of time and
have everything as quiet as possible
either to think either to think about
sound or to think about ideas or just to
just to focus on things that are
important to me so I do that the barn
where I work I mean it's only 15 minutes
or so from harvard square so it's it's
very close to the center of boston but
it happens to be a total oasis it's
completely quiet in there you'd think
you were out in I don't know the forest
somewhere and at the same time i work at
MIT which is you know this lab which is
the center of high technology and new
ideas and their people all over the
place and it's it's it's very it's a
very beautiful building actually but
it's um you know it's quite intense and
they're always people who want to talk
to you about something and so I kind of
go back and forth but one of the things
I like most of all is being in my study
in my barn with absolutely no sound
anywhere thinking about something yeah
it's it's extremely important to me